in China seemingly simple things still
pose barriers and blocks arriving at a
station is no exception
catching a train from Shanghai to
Beijing might once have been a very easy
thing to do but not now
if the zero covert commitment here still
dictates the lay of the land Congress
has turbocharged it it is quite
remarkable just how much it's taken to
travel between what used to be two of
the most International cities in the
world Beijing right now nothing short of
a digitized fortress and although things
are heightened because of Congress it
does give you a bit of a snapshot of
what life is like in China at the moment
so very dominated by zero covert and
it's
in Beijing itself this is now part of
everyday life
entirely dictates the ordinary lives of
Ordinary People
like Mrs Guan who can't visit her
hometown for fear of her child missing
school if you travel out of Beijing you
could be home quarantined for seven days
she says we only have seven days holiday
there's a sense people are restless if
resigned a little cue for some time
every three days
and that must sometimes feel a bit
frustrating yeah yeah
but tempers are fraying patience is thin
this recently from Shenzhen Province
people under lockdown cracking clashing
and it's not just lives held back but
livelihoods too the consumer economy
crippled and there's record young people
out of work Gigi lost her job earlier
this year
she wanted her identity hidden her voice
distorted such as the risk here of
questioning government she's not against
covert rules just painfully aware of the
impact
I think there will be a period of
suffering the party Congress has
proposed goals
and there will definitely be some
difficult times the goals that we may
have achieved in one to two years or
three to four years before may not be
achieved at this speed now
criticizing the rules here is seen as
akin to criticizing the government for
top leaders gathering this week a
victory narrative is needed increasingly
they are monitoring public moves as well
and the public are beginning to switch
actually increasingly people are saying
or maybe zero covet is much more
dangerous than covet itself China is
almost the only country in the world on
this path lives they say must come first
but there are other costs underneath the
control cracks too Helen Ann Smith Sky
News in Beijing